all right this is from The Daily Mail
a hospital banned a sex assault victim
from having an operation after she asked
for a all-female nursing care because of
safety concerns over mixed facilities
now the patient a feminist retired
lawyer
um
that is is the daily mails referring to
only as Emma
was told by London's Princess Grace
Hospital that it had to protect staff
from unacceptable distress
so she had been due to have complex
colorectal surgery at the premises on
October 10th and had filled in a
pre-admission form detailing her
requirements Emma who lives in North
London asked for single sex
accommodation and as per her beliefs did
not wish to use pronouns or engage with
such manifestations of gender ideology
she told mail online I was not going to
agree to fill in reams of Hospital
paperwork about my non-existent gender
identity or give my pronouns to anyone
the hospital is one of the only uh one
of only a handful to use the da Vinci
robot which can perform delicate and
complex operations and was selected for
that reason but when she arrived on
October 6 for her clinical pre-op
assessment which involved intimate
procedures what appeared to be a
transgender woman otherwise known as a
man and a blonde wig and makeup opened
the door and made eye contact with her
the encounter prompted her to complain
and to make an urgent extra request for
all female nursing care Emma told mail
online I began to wonder if it was just
a coincidence that this member of the
staff with a gender identity had made
their presence felt to me in such an
inappropriate way during my first visit
I began to suspect that I had been
targeted because my patient records show
that I refuse to reuse use pronouns and
wanted Single Sex facilities although I
have no evidence of this then I began to
panic that men would be attending to my
intimate Care at the hospital while I
was immobilized for an entire week
following major surgery
it was a slow draining realization I
felt sick alarm Bells were ringing in my
head I cannot describe the fear that I
felt I cannot rationalize it she wrote
to HCA that that evening underlining her
concerns and her beliefs relating to
gender women's rights Emma cited The
Landmark case
um involving Maya forestator which said
gender critical beliefs were protected
under the equality act and worthy of
respect
okay so that just to summarize from here
so she's at she's at the hospital for
this uh as they put it intimate
procedure
and or she's going to be very you know
sort of vulnerable and she made the
request ahead of time
that she only wants female staff and all
this was was known ahead of time
and uh it ends with the hospital telling
her that well actually we can't honor
that request
because because you know if you if you
want to get the surgery here then we're
going to include men in it who claim
that they're women
because they said it's distressing it's
distressing to the man dressed as a
woman if he's not allowed to be involved
in your procedure
it's distressing to him
and so they end up canceling the
procedure that she desperately needs
okay this is not a cosmetic procedure
this is this is a desperately needed
medical procedure that they canceled
because
she didn't want
you know she wanted her privacy
respective
what they what they told her was you can
have your privacy and your dignity or
you can get the necessary medical
procedure but you can't have all of
those things
this is another one of those cases where
yeah you see this and and uh
the the Temptation especially on the
right is to make the point right that
the hospital as we as we see so often
the hospital is putting the feelings of
the trans person over the physical
safety and physical well-being of a
woman you know they're putting safety
they're putting feelings over safety and
physical well-being and that's true that
is what they're doing that's the same
thing that happens when they allow men
into women's locker room it's a we see
that all over the place
but when we make this argument it
doesn't
it doesn't sink in on the left and the
reason it doesn't sink in is because
before you can even make that argument
you first have to explain
why physical safety and physical
well-being are more important than
feelings because that's not how they see
it I mean they really believe that the
most important thing in life are your
feelings and that is in fact more
important even than your own physical
safety
that's like the only reason that you
exist is is for your feelings the only
reason that anyone else in the world
exists is to affirm and validate your
feelings make you feel better about
yourself that's the way they see it
which is insane and twisted and upside
down
but it's one of the reasons why
sometimes I I think that the the better
argument here
which which by All rights is a worse
argument but kind of arguing on their
terms a little bit using their terms
against them
okay let's take physical safety out of
it then
even though that's obviously more
important than feelings but okay let's
put that aside
so then okay we have a competition of
feelings then
so it's the feeling of this guy
he's going to be distressed if he's not
allowed to be involved
versus the feelings of the woman
she'll be distressed if he is involved
so if feelings are primary which I'm not
admitting or agreeing that they are but
according to you they are so
we've got the males feelings versus the
females feelings
whose feelings come first
well obviously they say that the male's
feelings come first but we should force
them to say that
force them to admit that what you are
saying is that this biological male his
feelings come before the feelings of
this woman and that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block
um hope to see you there if not hope to
at least see out at the rally today and
if not then then on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]